لا واشهد ان لا اله الا الله
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله اللهم صل وسلم
وبارك على نبينا محمد
وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين اما بعد
درسنا موصول
في كتاب زاد المعاد
بهدي او من هدي خير العباد
للامام الحافظ القيم ابن القيم رحمه الله
تعالى شمس الدين
ووصلنا الى
نهايه بناء مسجد رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم
ثم ذكر المؤلف رحمه الله تعالى مساله
المؤاخاه
والعمليه عمليه التاخي التي اجراها النبي
صلى الله عليه وسلم
بين المهاجرين والانصار هذه العمليه في
غايه الاهميه
في غايه الاهميه
لماذا
لان الاصل ان الناس
يتفرقون على حسب
مكانهم على حسب العائله على حسب القبيله
المهاجرون جاءوا من مكه ووصلوا الى
المدينه
وكان الذي ينبغي
لتقوم دوله الاسلام حق القيام
وليقوم الصحابه
بالتواد والتحاب في الله سبحانه وتعالى حق
الحب
كان
يجب ان
ينسجموا
مع بعض ويدخلوا مع بعض الاصل انه جماعه
جايين مهاجرين الى بلد انه يكون الهم مثل
المخيم في البلد
وبعدين على مر الايام وعلى مر السنين
يبنون بيوتا وهكذا ويكون مكان المهاجرين
ومكان الانصار والنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
لم يرد ذلك
بل اراد ان
يكون التاخي بينهم
والاخوه التامه حتى لا يفرق
الانصار بين
المهاجر والانصار ولا يفرق المهاجر بين
المهاجرين والانصار في مساله التواد
والمحبه
فالنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم اخذ اول تسعين
من
المهاجرين والانصار ومن ابرز المهاجرين
والانصار ومن عظماء
كل منهما
واخى بينهم وهذه الاخوه كانت
فائقه للاخوه التي بالدم فكان في بدايه
الامر
ان
الاخ المهاجر يرث من اخيه الانصاري
والاخ الانصاري يرث من اخيه المهاجر
والاخوه كانت اخوه تامه
يقول ابن القيم رحمه الله ثم اخى بين
المهاجرين والانصار وكانوا تسعين رجلا
نصفهم من المهاجرين ونصفهم من الانصار على
المواساه
المواساه في اللغه
هو من
السواء وهو التساوي بين الامور فالمواساه
ان يكون
يد
الانصاري ويد اخيه المهاجر
كاليد الواحده ماليه فهو لاخيه هذه اسمها
مواساه
قال ويتوارثون بعد الموت الى وقعه بدر
فلما نزلت واولو الارحام بعضهم اولى ببعض
الايه وهي الايه الخاتمه الاخيره من سوره
الانفال رد التوارث الى الرحم وقيل انه
اخى بين المهاجرين الثانيه واتخذ عاليا
اخا والاول اثبت هذا لم يذكره الا القليل
من العلماء
المؤرخين وهو قول يعتبر قولا شاذا
وعمليه التاخي لم تكن بمكه وانما كانت في
المدينه مره واحده ولو كان ذلك يقول ابن
القيم لو كان في تاخي كما يزعم بعض
المؤرخين في مكه
ولو كان ذلك لكان احق الناس باخوته الصديق
الذي قال فيه لو كنت متخذا من امتي خليلا
لاتخذت ابا بكر خليلا ولكن اخي وصاحبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم وهذه الاخوه وان كانت عامه
كما قال وددت ان قد راينا اخواننا قالوا
السنا اخوانك قال انتم اصحابي
واخواني قوم ياتون من بعدي يؤمنون بي ولم
يروني اسال الله تعالى ان يكتبني واياكم
منهم
فللصديق من هذه الاخوه اعلى مراتبها كماله
من الصحبه اعلم راتبها
وودع من بالمدينه من اليهود وكتب بينه
وبينهم كتابا
وبادر حبرهم عبد الله بن سلام فدخل في
الاسلام وفي الجلسه الماضيه ذكرنا هذه
التفاصيل
وابى عمتهم الا الكفر وكانوا ثلاث قبائل
قينقاع والنضير وقريضه
وحاربه الثلاثه فمن على قين قاع كما يقول
الله عز وجل تجدن اشد الناس
عداوه للذين امنوا اليهود والذين اشركوا
فهؤلاء هم اشدهم والمفروض انه اليهود ما
يشتركوا مع المشركين ضد المسلمين لان
المسلم اقرب الى
دينه ومعتقده من المشركين عباد الاصنام
ولكن اليهود الذي يغلب عليهم الحسد ويغلب
عليهم
الفجور ونقض العهود فهم اشد الناس عداوه
للذين امنوا يقول فدخل في الاسلام
وابا عمتهم الا الكفر وكانوا ثلاث قبائل
قيل قاع والنضير وقريضه وحاربه الثلاثه
فمن على قين قاع
من عليهم بمعنى عفا عنه
وهذا المن كان بسبب
عبد الله بن ابي بن سلول رئيس المنافقين
والذي توسط
لقينقاع ان يعفو عنهم النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم ففعل
وهكذا عبد الله بن ابي
يتوسط لاعداء الاسلام
ويهاجم صحابه رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم فله من الله ما يستحق يقول واجلى
النظير بني النضير اجلاهم بمعنى انه
هجرهم من المدينه تماما وهذا الاجلاء كان
لنقد العهد
نقضوا العهد الذي عاهدوا به رسول الله صلى
الله عليه وسلم
فماذا كان من امرهم اجلاهم
وقتل قريظه لان قريظه هي اشد هذه القبائل
الثلاثه عداوه للمسلمين قريظه نقضوا العهد
في
زمن المعركه يعني كانت معركه الاحزاب
وغزوه الاحزاب قائمه
وهي تقريبا 20 يوم
عندهم
الخندق الاحزاب يعرف ايضا بغزوه الخندق
حفروا خندقا كبيرا طويلا
باشاره سلمان رضي الله عنه وهذه حركه
عسكريه من الفرس الفرس كانوا يعملون هذه
الخنادق
فحفروا هذا الخندق العميق وهذا الخندق
تقريبا
عمقه سته امتار تقريبا
يعني عميق
وكذلك طوله يزيد على 500 متر
تصور يعني هذا الخندق الضخم الذي حفروه في
الصحراء
فالخندق هذا
شانه ان
الفرسان او الجنود لا يستطيعون ان يقطعوا
مباشره على المدينه لابد انه ينزل في
الخندق ويطلع فلما ينزل في الخندق ويطلع
المسلمين على باب الخندق
يدرؤونهم ويردونهم بالنبل
حفروا هذا الخندق في
يعني عند
مقدمه المدينه جعلوا هذا الخندق ووقف
المسلمون النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
وصحابته يدرؤون عن هذا الخندق وخلف
المدينه
على باب من ابوابها قريظه
قريظه كان عاهدهم النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم ان يدفعوا عن المدينه من الوراء ما
يدخلوا حدا من ورا
وقريضه
قامت مش بس بنقض العهد مش بس انهم يدخلوا
العدو كمان انهم يغزوا مع العدو على النبي
صلى الله عليه وسلم واصحابه هذا في وقت
معركه الخندق هذه جريمه عظمه فالنبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم
كتب فيهم او اجرى فيهم السيف بسبب ذلك قال
وسبى ذريتهم
ونزلت سوره الحشر في النظير والاحزاب في
قريظه بدك تقرا عن
اجلاء بني النضير تقرا سوره الحشر بدك
تقرا عن قتال قريظه تقرا في سوره الاحزاب
وهكذا الحمد لله
الله عز وجل جعل لكل غزوه عظمى سوره في
القران يتحدث عنها فمثلا سوره ال عمران في
غزوه احد سوره الانفال غزوه بدر سوره
التوبه في غزوه تبوك وهلم جره
يقول وكان يصلي الى بيت المقدس وقال
لجبريل وددت ان الله صرف وجهي عن قبله
اليهود
فقال انما انا عبد فادعو ربك واساله فجعل
يقلب وجهه في السماء يرجو ذلك فانزل الله
عليه قد نرى تقلب وجهك في السماء الايه
ايش يعني تقلب وجهك في السماء يعني ان
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم يدعو الله
ويحث ويكون حثيثا بالدعاء فينظر الى
السماء وهذه النظر الى السماء نقلت عنه
صلى الله عليه وسلم في ادعيته العظيمه نقل
عنه في السنن انه كان ينظر الى السماء
حينما يدعو دعاء الخروج من المنزل الحديث
فيه نوع من الضعف لكن نستفيد من هذه
الروايه
ان النظر الى السماء وقت الدعاء امر جائز
بل قد يكون قد يكون شيئا
بل هو امر ان شاء الله من ما يعين او يسدد
الدعاء من اسباب قبول الدعاء كما ان رفع
اليدين من اسباب
قبول الدعاء
لكن هذا لا يجوز متى في الصلاه الصلاه
يحرم على المصلي ان يرفع بصره الى السماء
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
ذكر ان الله عز وجل كاد ان يخطف ابصاره
الناس الذين هم في الصلاه يرفعون ابصارهم
الى السماء هذا في الصلاه الصلاه لا يجوز
رفع البصر
الى الاعلى
وهذه مساله منتشره جدا في صلاه العامه
الناس خاصه بعد الركوع صح ولا لا لكن
الواحد بركع بعد ان سمع الله لمن حمده
وكمان انتشرت هذه مساله رفع اليدين هكذا
بعد
الركوع هذا لم يؤثر على النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم
وانما كان يرفع يديه حذو المنكبين او حذو
الاذنين وشحمه الاذنين صلى الله عليه وسلم
وكما في
سنن البيهقي
كان صلى الله عليه وسلم
توجهوا بكفيه الى
القبله فيرفع يديه هكذا ليس قابضا لاصابعه
ولا
ناشرا اياها وهو يرفع يديها هكذا
رفع البصر الى السماء ورفع اليدين بهذه
الصفات التي نراها
فانها غير
ليست من السنه ورفع البصر
يذكر العلماء انه محرم في الصلاه امر يحرم
في الصلاه
لكن في خارج الصلاه ما في مانع بل ومن
تعظيم الله سبحانه وتعالى ان الانسان يرفع
يديه ويقلب وجهه في السماء يرجو اجابه
الله سبحانه وتعالى
لماذا كان النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم يريد
ان يتجه ان يتجه الى الكعبه
وكان متجها في صلاته الى بيت المقدس هذه
قصه مهمه جدا في تاريخ الاسلام
وحتى نفهم اصل توجهنا الى القبله وقبله
الانبياء النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم من اول
من اول تشريع الصلاه
الى السنه الثانيه
بعد الهجره
كانت قبلته
كانت قبلته بيت المقدس
اتجه الى الاقصى الى القدس
وهكذا كان يصنع اليهود اليهود في صلاتهم
كانوا يتجهون ايضا الى
الى القدس الى بيت المقدس ويعظمونه وحقيق
هو بالتعظيم
والله عز وجل
يقول في القران
ان اول بيت وضع للناس
للذي ببكه
ايش يعني بكه
يعني مكه
هذه لغه في الميم الميم والباء
تجانس المخرج نفسه من الشفتين فيجوز
قول بكه ومكه
وقيل ان هذا لغه قريش اصلا
كانوا يقولون بكه
بكه ومكه نفس الشيء فالله عز وجل يقول ان
اول بيت وضع للناس للذي ببكه
هذا اول بيت وضع
ورجح كثير من العلماء
من هم الشنقيطي رحمه الله
محمد امين
الشيخ المفسر الجليل الاصولي ذكر في
اضوائه اضواء البيان في تفسير القران
بالقران
ذكر ان رجح ان اول بيت وضع للناس
الكعبه
وبناء هذا البيت كان بيد ادم عليه السلام
ادم هو الذي بنى الكعبه في بادئ الامر في
اول الامر يعني اول ما نزل ادم عليه
السلام انزل هو وزوجه من الجنه قام ببناء
ايش بناء مسجد ليعبدوا الله سبحانه وتعالى
هو وذرياته
فقام ببناء الكعبه في هذا المكان المبارك
وهذا هو الاصل
والانبياء عن اخرهم كانوا يتوجهون في
صلاتهم الى الكعبه
من وقت ادم عليه السلام
وبعض الناس
يذكر وهو قول لبعض العلماء بل لجمهور
العلماء ان الذي هو اول مسجد والذي بناه
للذي ببكه هو ابراهيم عليه السلام وهذا هو
المشهور
لكن ابراهيم عليه السلام جاء قبله انبياء
كثر
وكانت قبلاتهم
الكعبه
واما الحديث الذي يذكر فيه النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم بناء
الكعبه
فهذا كان ترميم واعاده بناء الكعبه
ابراهيم عليه السلام هو واسماعيل قام
باعاده البناء
لذلك يقول الله عز وجل واذ يرفع ابراهيم
القواعد من البيت يعني القواعد موجوده وهو
يرفعها لماذا لانه الكعبه حجر وطين
واذا مع الزمن والسيول والمطر والهوى
والشمس وهذه الاشياء الكعبه تحتاج الى
ترميم واعاده بناء
اعظم
اعاده لبناء الكعبه
كان بناء ابراهيم عليه السلام للكعبه اذ
كانت مهدومه
و تكاد تكون ممحوقه وما حد يعرف عنها وما
في حدا ساكن هناك فامر الله عز وجل ان
ياخذ هاجر وابنه اسماعيل
ليسكن ذلك البقعه المباركه ثم عاد
وبنى الكعبه هو واسماعيل عليه السلام يعني
اعادوا بناء الكعبه اذا فهمنا هذه المساله
نعرف ماذا نعرف انه
اصل قبله الانبياء كلهم
الكعبه
ولذلك النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم كان يرجو
ان يتوجه الى الكعبه
وكان في بدايه الامر لما كان في مكه كانت
المساله سهله كيف يجمع بين القبلتين
يعني كما ذكر ابن كثير رحمه الله
يقف ويجعل الكعبه بين يديه
وبيت المقدس من وراء الكعبه ويصلي فالان
ماذا صلى الى القبلتين جمع بينهم
لكن لما هاجر الى المدينه
ماذا حصل صارت الكعبه
وراءه وبيت المقدس يستقبله فاذا استقبل
بيت المقدس استدبره مكه والعكس
فهو لما هاجر الى المدينه بطل يعرف يجمع
بين القبلتين صار الحين بده يصلي الى بيت
المقدس وكان يكره الا يكون متوجها الى اصل
قبله الانبياء
الكعبه
طيب اذا كانت الكعبه هي اصل قبله الانبياء
لماذا كانت اليهود تصلي الى بيت المقدس
ولماذا شرع الله عز وجل لنبيه صلى الله
عليه وسلم ان يستقبل بيت المقدس اكثر من
عقد من الزمان الجواب على ذلك ما رجحه شيخ
الاسلام رحمه الله ان
التوجه الى بيت المقدس كان امرا طارئا
مبتدعا من اهل الكتاب وتوارثوه بعد
اعاده بناء بيت المقدس من قبل يعقوب عليه
السلام لما يعقوب عليه السلام بنى بيت
المقدس وبعدين جاء
جاءت الفتوحات وكانت
الامور هذه
الحروب وكانت كان ملك بني اسرائيل الاصل
انه هناك
صاروا يتوجهوا الى بيت المقدس وبعضهم ذكر
ان حينما ولد عيسى عليه السلام
ببيت المقدس فانهم
اصبحوا يتوجهون الى بيت المقدس في الصلاه
على ايه حال هي مساله
كانت خاصه باليهود
والله عز وجل من حكمته جعل النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم يوافق اليهود على قبلتهم في
بادئ الامر
هي حكمه عظيمه جدا
لان النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
دعوته دعوه الانبياء والرسل
الا انه من بني اسماعيل
واليهود من بني اسحاق من بني اسرائيل
فلذلك قال الله عز وجل لليهود
قال لهم
ولا تكونوا اول كافر به
انتم جماعه
حاملين التوراه وبقايا من
شريعه موسى عليه السلام والانبياء من بعده
وانتم تعرفون هذا النبي كما يعرف احدكم
ابنه كما تعرفون ابنائكم فلا تكونوا اول
كافر به المفروض تكونوا اول ايش اول مؤمن
به
وكان عليهم حق
حق عظيم جدا ان يتبعوا هذا القران وهذا
النبي الذي جاء
بما هو مصدق لما بين يديه من الكتاب لكتاب
موسى عليه السلام
فتوجهوا الى بيت المقدس
ولما هاجر النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم الى
مكه
جعل يصلي الى بيت المقدس
فلما ظهر النفاق
في المدينه
قال بعض اليهود يدخلون في الاسلام
ويصلون الى نفس الاتجاه
لكن عمي بصلي معاهم بس انا بصلي الى بيت
المقدس اصلا فما في مانع
فلما غير الله سبحانه وتعالى اتجاه القبله
قسم الناس الحين صار الذين يقولون سمعنا
واطعنا
واينما تولوا فثم وجه الله
وصار الجماعه الذين سماهم الله سفهاء
سيقول السفهاء من الناس ما ولاهم عن
قبلتهم التي كانوا عليها قل لله المشرق
والمغرب يهدي من يشاء الى صراط مستقيم
فجعل الله اتجاه الرسول محمد صلى الله
عليه وسلم الى مكه الى الكعبه جعله من
الهدى الى صراط مستقيم اسمعوا الايه سيقول
السفهاء من الناس ما ولاهم عن قبلتهم التي
كانوا عليها قل لله المشرق والمغرب يهدي
من يشاء الى صراط مستقيم فجعل هذا من ايش
من الصراط المستقيم
فاعاد الامر الى نصابه فجعل النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم واماته
يتوجهون الى قبله الانبياء لذلك
كان النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم يقلب وجهه
في السماء يرجو
ان يتوجه الى الكعبه في صلاته قال الله
تعالى قد نرى تقلب وجهك في السماء فلا
نولينك قبله ترضاها فولي وجهك شطر المسجد
الحرام وحيث ما كنتم فولوا وجوهكم شطره
وان الذين
اوتوا الكتاب ليعلمون انه الحق من ربهم
وما الله بغافل عما يعملون
فهم يعلمون ان الاتجاه الى بيت المقدس ليس
هو ليس هو الاصل وانه من جمله بدعهم التي
اقرها الله سبحانه وتعالى في بدايه
الاسلام
امتحان له
فاذا فهمنا هذه القصه
نفهم هذه الايات التي جاءت
في سوره البقره سيقول السفهاء من الناس ما
ولاهم عن قبلتهم التي كانوا عليها قل لله
المشرق والمغرب يهدي من يشاء الى صراط
مستقيم
وكذلك جعلناكم امه وسطا
لتكونوا شهداء على الناس ويكون الرسول
عليكم شهيدا وما جعلنا القبله التي كنت
عليها الا لنعلم من يتبع الرسول ممن ينقلب
على عقبيه
فهذه الايات تتضح لنا حينئذ ان الله يقول
يهدي من يشاء الى صراط مستقيم
وان الذين اوتوا الكتاب ليعلمون انه الحق
من ربهم وما الله بغافل عما تعملون
يقول ابن القيم رحمه الله
وذلك بعد سته عشر شهرا من مقدمه المدينه
قبل بدر بشهرين
قبل بدر بشهرين هل كانت تم
غزوات او معارك خفيفه قبل بدر نعم
كانت بعض
السرايا بعثت قبل بدر لكن معركه بدر هي
المعركه الاولى التي
كان معركه محسوبه الناس كلهم ينظرون من
يفوز في هذه المراه المعركه فذلك يكون سيد
العرب يقول وكان في ذلك حكم عظيمه
ومحنه للمسلمين والمشركين واليهود
والمنافقين
فاما المسلمون فقالوا امنا به كل من عند
ربنا وهم الذين هدى الله
ولم تكن كبيره عليهم واما المشركون فقالوا
كما رجع الى قبلتنا يوشك ان يرجع الى
ديننا
وما رجع اليها الا انها الحق
واما اليهود فقالوا خالف قبله الانبياء
قبله واما المنافقون فقالوا ما يدري اين
يتوجه ان كانت الاولى حقا فقد تركها وان
كانت الثانيه هي الحق فقد كان على باطل
وكثرت اقاويل السفهاء من الناس وكانت كما
قال الله تعالى
وانها لكبيره الا على الذين هدى الله
وكانت محنه من الله ليرى من يتبع من يتبع
الرسول ممن ينقلب على عقبيه ولما كان شان
القبله عظيما وطا سبحانه قبلها امر النسخ
وقدرتي عليه
وانه ياتي بخير من المنسوخ او مثله ثم
عقبه بالتوبيخ لمن تعنت على رسوله ولم
ينقذ له
هذه المساله هي من اعظم ادله العلماء على
اجماعهم على وقوع النسخ في احكام الله
سبحانه وتعالى
جماعه طلعوا زمان
كل الجماعه كانوا في عهد التابعين
وبدايات عهد تابعيهم
فاروا يتعلموا من فلسفه اليونان
الفتوحات الاسلاميه
ارتدت وانتشرت الدوله الاسلاميه وفي
الاسلام احنا عنا محافظه عظيمه
للعلم العلم يعني هذا الدين دين العلماء
فكان المسلمون والخلفاء في ذاك الزمن
يحترمون العلم
الى درجه انهم احترموا علوما ليست بمحترمه
اعيد الكلام احترموا اشياء وعلوم وكتبا
ليست هي محترمه ما كانت ينبغي ان تحترم
لكن كما ذكرنا كثيرا
شهوه العلم مثل شهوه المال سواء بسواء
الانسان
ومخلوق ومن اعظم
ما هو من شانه العلم
الله عز وجل اسجد الملائكه لادم بماذا
بالعلم
وعلم ادم الاسماء كلها
شرف الانسان ليس في قوه جسده ولا بل هو في
العلم
هذا العلم مغروس في الانسان
انه بطبعه يريد ان يفهم
يسال لماذا كيف وبما
والانسان اذا ما علم الشيء
هكذا ذلك في صدره يريد ان يعلم
هذا طيب وجيد واول ايه الله عز وجل انزلها
اقرا ماشي
لكن المشكله
انه الانسان اذا طمع
دخل يعوم في جميع العلم مما هو محترم وغير
محترم ومما هو نافع وغير نافع قد يهلك
يكون سببا في هلاك او هلاك غيره
لذلك النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم كان يستعيذ
بالله من علم لا ينفع صح ولا لا كان
يستعيد اعوذ بالله اللهم اني اعوذ بك من
علم لا ينفع
لان العلم الذي لا ينفع فانه اقرب الى
الضرر
فما بالك بالعلم الذي يضر
هل في علم نعم في علم يضر
علم الفجور وعلم السحر وعلم التنجيم وعلم
الفلسفه الكافره وافكار الكفار وكيف
يتحججون على الانبياء هذه علوم ما ينبغي
للانسان ان يتعلمها الا اذا اضطر الى ذلك
عالم من علماء الاسلام لابطال هذه الشبه
وحتى العلماء
العلماء كثر
عرفوا بالدخول في علم الكلام والخوض في
هذه الامور مثل
الغزالي رحمه الله والرازي
وامام الحرمين والجوين
تاج الدين السبكي
خاضوا في هذه الاشياء
وابتلعوا هذه العلوم فلما ارادوا ان
يتقيؤوها لم يستطيعوا لزكت في بطونهم
لزكت في بطونهم ما عرف يطلعها بعد ما
دخلها عندهم شبه وكلام وفلسفات واشياء
يعني
اشياء هي في ضياع الوقت يعني كما قال شيخ
الاسلام رحمه الله
يقول علم الكلام
مثل
لحم
جمل غث على راس جبل وعر
كلمه جميله جدا رحمه الله
ويقول علم الكلام
كلحم جمل
على راس جبل وعر
ايش معنى هذا الكلام لحم الجمال العادي
فيه انه ايش كاسي
وقصه الجمل
هي ليست لحمه يعني مرغوبه او مطلوبه مثل
اللحوم الاخرى
لكن على فوقها بتحط اللحمه على راس جبل
وعر بدك تجهد نفسك وتطلع الجبل وتقتل حالك
على ايش على لحم الجمل في نهايه المطر
فهو يقول ذلك رحمه الله لماذا
يقول شيخ الاسلام رحمه الله علم الكلام
اكثره في الباطل لكن
ما حققوه من حق فهو عن ابعد طريق الى الحق
ويقول مثال ذلك ان يقالوا
للانسان امسك
باذنك اليمنى فيلف بيده الشمال ويمسك هيك
ما يمسك هيك يعني هيها لا بده يطلع وبده
يلوظ ويطلع من اصعب طريق عشان يحقق شيء
وحق
لذلك الف العلماء حتى علماء الكلام نفسهم
الفوا كتبا في تحريم علم الكلام على
العوام حتى كتب من اشهر ذلك
الامام الحرمين الجام العوام عن علم
الكلام
الجام العوام عن علم الكلام
وكلحم جمل غث في راس جبل وعر
وما توصلوا اليه من حق فهو عن ابعد طريق
ممكن
باحترام المسلمين وعلماء الاسلام للعلم
قلنا هذه الشهوه شهوه العلم مثل شهوه ايش
مثل شهوه المال تماما
الانسان اذا ما شافي دم وهذا الشيء وما
حدد انه بس يتعلم العلوم النافعه المهمه
الطارئه
فانه ماذا يدخل في علوم لا تنفع واسوى من
ذلك علوم تضره
وهذا الذي حصل
فاجا الجماعه من المسلمين
وتعلموا هذه العلوم دخلوا في اليونان
دخلوا في
فارس دخلوا في المناطق هاي
واخذوا الكتب
وترجموها كلها
ترجموها كلها كتب ايش كتب فلسفه
كتب
والجماعه هذول
الذين يقولون ان كان يوجد هناك رب فلا بد
انه يكون صفاته واحد اثنين ثلاثه ومش ممكن
يكون صفاته غير هذه
فبتعلم الانسان هذه المساله ويظن ان صريح
العقل يحقق هذا بعدين يرجع للقران يجد
مخالفه
فبيصير بده ياخذ القران ويلويه عشان يدخله
في هذه القربه بدل ما هو العكس
افتتن الناس
وظهرت جماعات
من اوائل هؤلاء الجماعات الذين تاثروا
بالفلسفه وعلم الكلام وعلم اليونان والفرس
والهند بل وكمان بعض علوم من الصين وعلم
كلام من هناك جماعه اسمهم الجهميه
طلع بعدهم جماعه اخرى فرخت طبعا البدع هيك
مثل شعله النار تبدا صغيرا وتنتشر
لان اجت جماعه المعتزله بعدين اجت جماعات
هذول الجماعات جابوا
فتن عظيمه على المسلمين
ومن هذه الفتن
انهم قالوا النسخ غير معقول في شريعه الله
سمعت الكلام مش ممكن انه يكون في شيء اسمه
ناسخ في القران ولا في السنه طب ليش يا
جماعه قالوا لا
كيف ربنا الذي يعلم كل شيء ينزل شيء
وبعدين ينقضه فيما بعد
اهل السنه قالوا يا جماعه الخير خليكم
معانا على الخط
نعم الناسخ في الاخبار غير معقوله يعني مش
ممكن ربنا يخبرنا عن خبر وبعدين يكذب هذا
الخبر لا
لكن الناس يقع وين في الاحكام
شيء مناسب للفتره هاي للوقت هذا ثم ياتي
شيء اخر غير مناسب
وصار النسخ في الخمر وصار الناسخ في اشياء
كثيره ومن النسخ استقبال الكعبه
تغيير القبله من النسخ مش في هذا من النسخ
هذول الجماعه طلعوا وكثير ليش انا بحكي عن
هذه الاشياء يعني الانسان ممكن يكون يعني
يا شيخ هذول جماعات القديمه الها فوق
الالف سنه
لا هي
فراخهم لسه موجوده وهذه الافكار موجوده
وصار في اخر عشر عشرين سنه
انتشار لهذه الشبه انتشار غير معقول مع
الانترنت ومع طباعه الكتب وانتشار الكتاب
والقراءه
وبطلع الدكتور فلان على الاذاعه
على
التلفاز
في الدول العربيه في غير الدول العربيه
ويقعد يلقي منها الشبه على الناس
وراح واخذوا هذه الشبه كلها واحياوها
والقوها بين الناس
وصاروا يشككوا في اشياء هي من مسلمات
الاسلام ما في واحد حتى سكن في بريه الا
ويعرف هذه الاشياء من الاسلام برجع بقول
لك لا
المسلمين كلهم غلطانين شفت قبل
قبل شهرين ثلاثه واحد عنده
سلسله سلسله
شرور كان بده يطلع يشرح للمسلمين وبده
يستدل بالقران انه ما في اشي اسمه خمس
صلوات في اليوم هي بس صلاتين ركعتين
طلوع الشمس والركعتين في غروب الشمس قالوا
انا انما ابين العلم والمسلم يختار شو
يختار المسلم هذه مساله مفتوحه للاختيار
والجدل
هذه الاشياء انتشرت ومن هذه الفتن فتنه
انه ما في اشي اسمه نسخ في القران فهذا
الان ان شاء الله نتناول هذه المساله
اكثر ان شاء الله في الجلسه القادمه
ونكتفي بهذا القدر الله اعلم وصلى الله
وسلم على نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه
اجمعين جزاكم الله خيرا